bonjour je m'appelle julia centrès et
j'ai travaillé sur l'image de marguerite
de valois la reine margot dans les
fictions audiovisuelles
c'est au beurre chaud tapoter la
première nuit ne m'a pas appelé margot
la flamme ne te plaît pas maintenant si
je prend lui le personnage de la reine
margot a hérité d'une légende noire et
rose puisque en fait dès son époque on a
des pamphlets qui font d'elle une femme
volage afin de déstabiliser les derniers
valois puis le nouveau roi henri iv sont
les poux et sur ce terreau s'est
construit tout au long du xixème et
xxème siècles un mythe misogyne qui
étaient chargés d'expliquer pourquoi les
femmes devaient être tenus en dehors de
la vie politique
et comme l'a montré éliane viennot on a
des romans des pièces de théâtre mais
aussi des livres d'histoire qui ont fait
d'elle une nymphomane parfois saute
parfois manipulatrice parfois
meurtrières en 1954 caen sort la reine
margot de jean dréville avec jeanne
moreau ce genre de film historique et
très critiqué sur le plan de la moralité
puisque on l'accuse de montrer trop de
scènes avec des femmes dévêtues et des
scènes d'orgies explicite en 61 la loi
debré durci la censure cinématographique
elle intègre à la commission de contrôle
des films des éducateurs des pédagogues
mais aussi des représentants des
associations familiales et des maires de
son côté on à la télévision qu'ils
adoptent le carré blanc dès lors comment
représenter la reine margot qui est
décrite par l'historiographie
contemporaine comme une débauche et
incestueuse l'arrivée de margaux au
petit écran s'accompagne d'un
assagissement du personnage et de sa
discrétion dans l'intrigué dans la
caméra explore le temps qui est regardé
par un public familial
la reine margot n'a plus aucun amant
elle se fait patriotes et justice hier
un soutien au trône des bourbons en
quelque sorte mais sa représentation
physique est figée elle est telle qu'on
l'a vu au cinéma dans la fiction elle
est censée avoir 58 ans et être bien en
chair mais on a affaire à une jeune
femme svelte
écoutez bien regardez bien dans
l'adaptation du drame de dumas en 61 la
reine margot n'a plus aucune ambition
personnelle mais elle sert celle de son
mari et de son amant paradoxalement
alors que les femmes peuvent désormais
représentés politiquement la nation
cette reine margot se cantonne à
l'intrigué amoureuse et délaisse
totalement la trique politique et que
j'ai appris votre danger je me suis
rappelé mon devoir va devoir d'une femme
et de partager le sort de son mari nous
exultons je pars vous en présentons je
suis captive et si on vous tue jamais
après l'éclatement de la rtf en 74 la
télévision réintroduit le thème de
l'inceste jusque là tabou dans ses mises
en scène les livres d'histoire
abandonnent leur rhétorique misogyne et
c'est la télévision qui se la
réapproprient j'ai aimé bien désarmée
certains passionnément mais georges eric
debard dessus tout henry avec lequel je
ne couche plus et toi avec islam est
défendu dans ces années 70
d'émancipation féministe on a une reine
margot qui apparaît comme un contre
modèle
on a une jeune femme qui ne peut
s'approcher du pouvoir politique
sauf à entraîner le pays à sa perte
cette thématique comme le rituel de la
cest seront repris dans le film de
patrice chéreau
[Musique]
non